en el vídeo pasado di la pista de que la
discusión se iba a orientar hacia una
oferta de dinero elástica es decir una
oferta de dinero que cambie según lo
necesite la economía antes de pasar a
esto en el vídeo pasado estuvimos
hablando acerca de los pagarés del
gobierno lo cual es un concepto clave
pero también vamos a repasar qué es eso
de la oferta de dinero teníamos dos
definiciones de eso y la primera vez que
hable acerca de m 0 simplemente me había
referido a las reservas en oro pero
ahora vamos a expandir un poquito más
esa definición y pues creo que ya más o
menos puedes pensar pues porque va a
tener mucho que ver con esto de que
queríamos salirnos del patrón oro y de
hecho ya casi casi nos salimos estamos a
un pasito ahora lo que vamos a
considerar como el dinero base van a ser
las notas bancarias de la reserva
federal y las cuentas de cheques ahí en
esta realidad en la que estábamos
trabajando todos los depósitos del banco
de la reserva central se habían
convertido en billetes sin embargo si
este banco lo hubiera deseado así
pudiera haber obtenido parte de sus
notas bancarias como una cuenta de
cheques en el banco de la reserva va
entonces una nota de la reserva y una
cuenta de cheques ahí es esencialmente
lo mismo
está bien sea una nota es un poco más
flexible porque se la das a quien sea y
nada más baila cambia y una cuenta de
cheques pues necesitas hacerle una
transferencia electrónica o escribir un
cheque pero bueno esto es a lo que le
vamos a llamar la oferta de dinero base
o nada más el dinero base también lo
podemos pensar como el lado derecho los
pasivos del banco de la reserva central
en términos muy generales ya después
veremos los detallitos metiéndonos con
una hoja de balance regresando al
ejemplo nuestra oferta de dinero base es
de 200 vamos a llamarles pesos vamos a
olvidarnos de las piezas de oro si por
cuestiones pedagógicas diremos que un
peso es una pieza de oro entonces
nuestra oferta de dinero base que es
algo que le vamos a llamar m 0 m 0 es
ahorita de 200 otra vez eso de ahí es el
efectivo que está circulando y además
son las cuentas en el banco de la
reserva federal por ejemplo esto de aquí
pudo haber sido simplemente 100 en la
cuenta de cheques en el banco de la
reserva federal así como esta de acá
podría ser una cuenta de cheques sin
embargo todavía lo consideramos como
parte del dinero base porque este banco
podría decir
y sabes que prefiero tener billetes el
banco de la reserva tendría que imprimir
billetes y claro cancelar la cuenta de
cheques entonces en el fondo son
equivalentes solo son diferentes formas
de mover el dinero
ahora hay una definición un poco más
amplia de dinero ya ésta le vamos a
llamar dinero base así le voy a llamar
pero ya sabemos que la definición formal
es m 1 esta definición es esa que vimos
hace un montón de vídeos como 11 o 12
que es cuánto dinero las personas creen
que tienen equivalente mente es la
cantidad de dinero que haya en cuentas
de cheques de bancos a ver en este
ejemplo es esto de aquí de modo que las
personas en este banco piensan que
tienen 100 pesos
ahí está esto de aquí son 100 pesos que
piensan que tienen y por los cuales
pueden escribir cheques este banco de
acá también tiene otros 100 pesos va
entonces el total de dinero bancario
aquí hay algo que está marchando mal a
no no no perdón no tienen 100 en total
más bien tienen a ver este banco tenía
100 en oro y podía prestar hasta el
doble verdad podía tener hasta 200 en
cuentas de cheques si más bien era esto
podría tener hasta 200 por eso me habían
salido las cuentas mal
si en el vídeo pasado habíamos hablado
de un coeficiente de reserva del 50% lo
cual nos dice que si este banco tiene
100 pesos en reservas entonces puede
emitir o más bien entonces puede manejar
hasta el doble hasta 200 en cuentas de
cheques en sus pasivos exigibles ya
sabes ya vimos muchas veces cómo
funcionaba esto y qué pasaría con este
otro banco pues también podría tener 200
en cuentas de cheques va entonces el
total de dinero que las personas de esta
ciudad creen que tienen ya sea en
cuentas de cheques o pues en cuentas de
cheques está más verdad ahorita estoy
asumiendo que todo el efectivo se queda
en el banco a lo mejor esto no es cierto
en la vida real pero ahorita vamos a
suponer que así es no sé por qué usan
tarjetas de débito todo el tiempo y de
hecho creo que estamos yéndonos hacia
allá en el mundo real y también esto
hace que aumente la oferta de dinero
pero bueno ahorita no me quiero meter
con esos detalles la cosa es que el m1
la suma de las cuentas de cheques de
todos es 400
si lo piensas esta relación de aquí
tiene muchísimo sentido porque el
coeficiente de reserva es de 50% yo creo
que podemos asumir que los bancos
intentan prestar lo más que puedan sin
pasarse del requisito porque pues porque
no obtienen interés por lo que tengan en
sus reservas nada más obtienen interés
por los préstamos que hacen en las
cuentas bancarias correspondientes así
si el coeficiente de reserva fuera de
10% y el dinero base fuera 200
esperaríamos tener un m1 de 2000 ahora
la pregunta que te quiero hacer y a lo
mejor te gustaría pausar el vídeo para
pensarlo es la siguiente cómo le puede
hacer el gobierno o el banco federal
para aumentar o disminuir la oferta de
dinero y claro a lo mejor una primera
pregunta más bien sería por qué aumentar
o disminuir la oferta de dinero bueno
esteban supongamos que ya estamos en
este mundo que sólo tiene dos bancos y
una oferta de dinero base de 200 y ahora
supongamos que así por alguna razón
inesperada la economía crece no sé a lo
mejor llegaron inmigrantes o inventamos
una nueva tecnología incluso puede ser
algo de temporada a lo mejor ahorita es
la temporada de plantar pues semillas un
montón de granjeros necesita
efectivo pues para contratar a gente que
haga los plantíos y que recoja los
frutos todo eso si no aumentamos la
oferta de dinero en los momentos en los
cuales hay expansión económica por
cualquier razón ya sea por temporada o
por alguna innovación tecnológica si no
aumenta la oferta de dinero entonces el
dinero se va a volver más caro después
voy a hacer un vídeo con más detalle
pero ahorita básicamente que el dinero
se vuelva más caro es que las tasas de
interés aumentan pero si el dinero se
vuelve muy caro entonces algunos
proyectos ya no se van a poder realizar
no sé a algunos granjeros no van a poder
hacer su planteo y entonces restringen
la economía no te preocupes después
vamos a tener una discusión bien sabrosa
de por qué querríamos hacer esto
ahorita mejor vamos a enfocarnos en cómo
lograrlo hay dos formas de hacerlo la
primera que es como medio obvia es
aumentar el coeficiente de reserva para
que los bancos puedan abrir más cuentas
de cheques si verdad si el requisito
estuviera un poco más leve entonces
podrían hacer más préstamos si fuera 10%
entonces tendríamos un m1 de que como
2.000 si verdad de 2000 sería diez veces
ese mesero en vez de nada más el doble
bueno esa es una primera opción y la
verdad si es una opción verdad si es una
herramienta del banco central por qué
practicamos que el banco central también
se va a encargar de establecer los
requisitos de coeficientes de reserva
sin embargo hay un pequeño problema con
modificar el coeficiente mira pensemos
lo así si nos vamos a un requisito del
10% entonces ahora los bancos van a
empezar a prestar de modo que sólo
tengan 10% en reservas o sea de modo que
la razón de entre sus reservas y sus
cuentas sea de 10% pero supongamos que
ahora como se acabó la temporada
queremos regresar el requisito a 50 por
ciento entonces ahí se la ponemos
dificilísima los bancos como le van a
hacer para regresar a un coeficiente de
50 por ciento pues no se tendrían que
por ejemplo empezar a vender sus activos
o empezar a pedir préstamos sería una
situación
latos y sima si disminuyes el requisito
de coeficiente de reserva y luego lo
aumentas vas a ocasionar que muchísimos
bancos se descapitalicen porque casi
todos los bancos operan pues justo al
límite de lo que les piden va entonces
no queremos meternos demasiado con este
numerito ok entonces la pregunta es si
no queremos meternos con el numerito
este con la razón entre las reservas y
las cuentas de cheques que podemos hacer
entonces cómo le hacemos pues la única
otra forma en la cual podemos aumentar
la cantidad de cuentas de cheques
incrementando las reservas es decir si
lográramos aumentar un poquito más de
reservas por aquí cuál es la nueva
pregunta cómo le hacemos para hacer esto
pues ahí te va con un poco de suerte ya
conocemos bien bien cómo funciona el
sistema de reserva fraccionaria
creo que ya ves hacia dónde va esto
verdad la cosa es que este sistema
también aplica para el banco de la
reserva central hasta ahorita todo había
estado respaldado en oro así uno a uno
sin embargo no hay ninguna razón para
que el banco de la reserva central no
pueda meterse en los préstamos con
reserva fraccionaria y de hecho el banco
de la reserva central no tiene un
requisito de coeficiente de reserva y no
lo tiene porque pues pues por lo que ya
platicamos porque todos sus préstamos
están respaldados por el gobierno que
tiene la capacidad de hacer más
impuestos y de pagar las deudas baja
entonces lo que puede hacer el banco de
la reserva central es lo siguiente va a
ser el siguiente mecanismo y justo a
esto es a lo que se le conoce como la
imprenta de dinero pero ojo van a ser
dos imprentas de dinero una va a ser del
dinero base y luego se va a apalancar al
dinero bancario otra vez me gustaría
platicar con eso con un poco más de
calma en otro vídeo porque habita
está acabando el tiempo vamos al
mecanismo lo que el banco de la reserva
central puede hacer en esta situación
número 1 va a imprimir más billetes así
literalmente digamos que imprime no sé
100 pesos en billetes cómo le hace para
hacer esto pues así literalmente nada
más va con tesorería y pide dinero para
unas impresiones y los imprime al hacer
esto al banco se le crea un pasivo
correspondiente que serían notas
bancarias pendientes un pasivo de 100
luego lo que va a hacer es tomar estos
100 pesos y no se ahorita son 100 pesos
en billetes podrían estar en cuentas de
cheques del banco de la reserva pero son
100 pesos ahorita en billetes va
entonces va a tomar estos 100 pesos en
billetes y con ellos va a comprar
pagarés del gobierno federal vamos a ver
qué sucede a ver si toma los 100 pesos y
con eso compra pagarés del gobierno y
ojo
ahorita no se los tiene porque comprar
directamente al gobierno porque pues
porque el gobierno ya se los vendió a
muchas personas en el mundo
siempre hay pagarés circulando por ahí
mientras que el gobierno siga teniendo
deudas va entonces digamos que yo tenía
un cierto pagaré del gobierno y voy a
dibujar por aquí al banco
yo tenía algunos pagarés que hace algún
tiempo le compré al gobierno federal y
ahorita lo que tiene el banco central
son estos 100 pesos en billetes que
acaba de imprimir que los sacó así y
fresquitos tiene 100 pesos déjame pintar
los mejores en verde ahí está ahí están
los 100 pesos y simplemente me compran
mi pagaré y no sé a lo mejor ahorita yo
no lo quiero vender así tan fácilmente
porque me sigue pagando interés entonces
me van a tener que pagar un poquito más
para que yo quiera venderlo después voy
a hacer un vídeo con más detalles de
cómo afecta la curva de ganancia y todo
eso por el momento solo quería darte
esta idea de la mecánica con la cual el
banco central crea un pasivo de notas
bancarias pendientes con lo cual tiene
un activo correspondiente de siempre son
billetes que así literalmente imprime y
con los cuales puede empezar a hacer
transacciones en el mercado abierto para
comprar o vender pagarés del gobierno
ahora vamos a ver qué efecto tenemos
para empezar estos 100 pesos ahora se
convirtieron en pagarés del gobierno
déjalo cambia el color de los pagarés
del gobierno me preguntadores la
siguiente
yo solía tener un pagaré pero ahora en
vez de tener un pagaré tengo 100 pesos
en billetes que voy a hacer con esos 100
pesos pues obvio no los voy a meter a la
cama y voy a querer meterlos en el banco
voy a depositarlos en el banco entonces
supongamos que este soy yo y estoy
depositando lo pues no sé digamos que
acá arriba mi cuenta de cheques también
creció un poquito pero mira cuál fue el
efecto colateral de repente el sistema
bancario ahora tiene más efectivo tiene
más dinero en reservas que va a aplicar
para cuando consideremos sus
coeficientes de reserva como tuvo un
depósito de 100 entonces puede hacer
otros 100 adicionales en préstamos
entonces número uno aumente el dinero
base m 0 pasó de ser 200 a ser 300 si
verdad porque el total de notas
bancarias pendientes es 300 pero además
el m1
cuando yo deposite mi billete de 100
pesos en el banco se aumentaron 100
pesos en mi cuenta de cheques pero
además por lo del coeficiente de reserva
del 50% el banco puede hacer otros 100
pesos en préstamos a ver si no queda muy
feo 400 ok entonces ahora el m1 es de
vale está súper padre entonces
simplemente con un mecanismo de
impresión de billetes y de compraventa
de pagarés del gobierno que el banco
central logró aumentar el valor de m1 el
dinero en cuentas en 200 pesos después
voy a hacer otros vídeos para no
confundirnos mucho ahorita nos vemos